so whatever you believe the truth to be
about the death of Jeffrey Epstein
there's a totally separate issue which
is why do so many Trump insiders end up
having connections to Jeffrey Epstein
and quick disclaimer anything even
remotely touching Jeffrey Epstein is
instantly demonetised by YouTube so
please consider supporting the show
directly so that we can keep covering
the stories we want to cover not having
to worry about whether they will be
monetizable or not Jeffrey Epstein died
in his jail cell on August 10th of an
alleged suicide under what are strange
conditions we can call them and I don't
need to go all conspiratorial the way in
which he was found the injury something
about it doesn't sound quite right to
lots of people and we may just never
know the exact truth about what went
down there okay the background of that
story has mostly been like the story
that has been prevailing in the media
but there's another story which is that
it's not just Trump himself whose link
to Epstein you might remember we had
that video of Trump and Epstein at a
party in the 90s I believe it was where
Trump and Epstein are standing there
together looking at and sort of
evaluating the attractiveness of
different young girls and of course
there's much more serious allegations
behind that as well it's not just Trump
there are also Trump insiders connected
to Epstein there's a growing list and
this latest one is truly bizarre so
Donald Trump's Treasury secretary is
Steven minuchin and Steven Mann Newton's
name appears on a legal document for a
company owned by jean-luc Brunel who's
in associative jeopardy a free epstein
so you've got Epstein his associate is
John Luke Brunel John Luke Brunel x'
company next management corporation
listed stephen minuchin as a quote state
point of contact for the corporation
this is another connection between
Epstein and Trump this time via Steven
minuchin and Brunel himself by the way
has also been accused of sexual assault
and
rape and of getting girls for Jeffrey
Epstein now obviously immediately the
media went right to the Treasury and
said why is Steven minuchin 's name
listed here
why is he listed as a representative for
john luke burnell's company treasury
spokesperson said it's quote not clear
why minuchin was listed and that
minuchin has no recollection of meeting
john luke Brunell in his life how
strange is that
minuchin is listed but the Treasury
Department says that it's simply
erroneous but as usual you sort of have
to read between the lines let's take a
look at the statement from the Treasury
Department where they say secretary
minuchin never served in any official
capacity in next management corporation
never did any business with nor knows
either of the Brunell brothers and never
had any ownership stake in next
management corporation or any related
entities secretary minuchin had no
knowledge whatsoever that he was listed
as a point of contact at an address he's
not familiar with for a company that
he's had no dealings with that listing
was clearly an error now I'm not
pretending I know the truth of this i I
really don't this it's bizarre I don't
know the truth of it but what I do know
is that I recognize what we call weasel
language when I see it if you look at
this statement he never served in an
official capacity it's not denying that
there could have been an unofficial
capacity in which he served he never had
an ownership stake in Brunel's company
of course an ownership stake is not
necessary to be in some way involved
with the company he didn't know that he
was listed as a contact well that is a
very different thing then there is no
reason whatsoever for him to be listed
as a contact he just didn't know it a
much like the others surrounding Epstein
Brunell disappeared from public view
after Epstein was found dead in August
and it's just yet another one of these
bizarre data points that links back to
Donald Trump and connection so the
practical question at this point is what
can we hope for what what Epstein is
dead what is it that we can hope to get
from the entire Jeffrey Epstein thing I
think that there are three things number
one we truly
definitively need to try to find out the
truth about Epstein's death I'm not
optimistic as I said that we're ever
going to know that to the full
satisfaction of those who find something
strange about the circumstances the
story is extremely odd it's difficult to
fully believe but okay that would be
number one priority what are the real
circumstances of Epstein's death number
two we want to find out the full truth
about any Trump involvement up to and
including the fact that Trump was
accused of raping a girl who was 13
years old at the time at Jeffery
Epstein's
Manhattan condo we want that exposed to
the fullest possible extent and then
number three Epstein's dead but Epstein
didn't work alone there were many people
involved in Epstein being a predator and
the third thing I can think of that
would be a priority would be for all of
those people to be discovered
investigated prosecuted when appropriate
and held responsible so we'll be
following it yet another just very
strange data point I think that that's
the way I would say it related to
Jeffrey Epstein and the many connections
to Donald Trump